for me I got 20 different motivators
under four different categories that
people have one is individual so you
have individual accomplishments you're
going after right you want to have a
degree to be able to say you want to
UCLA or you want to pan you want to
Wharton that's an individual
accomplishment makes you proud right
individually you want to have a car a
watch clothes you know a house whatever
right that's individual accomplishments
those will run out eventually if it's
just individual then you have one that's
lifestyle lifestyle is purely selfish
stuff that you want the other one is a
purpose you know I want to do something
big and memorable and the last one is
madness madness is you know Michael
Jordan is part of Madness Community Tom
Brady is part of Madness Community
Connor is part of Madness Community I
mean you can go down a bunch of people
you know that are part of Madness
Community you'll know if you're part of
Madness Community or you're not part of
Madness community